grocery shopping is getting an overhaul
a whole raft of companies are entering
the grocery delivery business notably
San Francisco's instacart so rather than
try the insta car app I decided to try
instacart work err overdressed the app
is the simple part pull up the app push
a button select your groceries and hit
order but behind the scenes it's
complicated and uber life
instacart contractors head to partner
stores like Whole Foods and Costco they
stroll the aisles pick the items poke
the produce check each portion and scan
every item as they go making sure they
get the right stuff instacart makes
money by charging four to six bucks an
order and sometimes charging customers
more than they paid if they actually
went to the store special checkout lanes
speed their purchase instacart operates
in fifteen markets and is growing
quickly dot-com history is littered with
the wreckage of failed delivery startups
like Cosmo urban fetch and Webvan but
this uber like smartphone powered out
sourced model may give instacart a
better ending there we go
you